[تصفيق]
أجنبي ،
هذا جحش طوله 45 جحشًا ، أول
شيء سأفعله هو أنني سأفحص
كل أسطوانة وسأريكم أن
جميع الأسطوانات الست فارغة ونحن
بأمان هل هذا مشابه لـ  الشخص الذي
استخدموه في فيلم الصدأ ، نعم ،
يجب أن يكون هذا هو نفس النموذج الذي استخدموه
في هذا الفيلم ، دعني أتطرق إليه
الذي يتحدث عنه الجميع وأبقه
موجهًا في اتجاه آمن ، لا تشير
إلي أو الكاميرا ، حسنًا  عادة
لا يمكنك توجيهها إلى الكاميرا على الإطلاق
ولكنهم فعلوا ذلك في حالة الصدأ بشكل جيد
وهناك ظروف نقوم بها
ونفعل ذلك بأمان شديد مع
حماية lexan بين البندقية
والكاميرا وقد نستخدم أحمال أخف
[موسيقى]
هذا النوع من المسدس هو مسدس غربي
ويستغرق وقتًا أطول للتحقق من كل
رصاصة ،
هل يمكنك أن تشرح للناس كيف
يعمل ، لذا فإن البنادق القديمة 1860s 1880s
هي ميكانيكية للغاية إذا كنت
تريد أن تنظر في الأسطوانة
وعليك أن تنظر في كل
أسطوانة واحدة في كل مرة  وهناك
ذراع ، قضيب يدفع للخارج ،
لذا عليك مسح جولة واحدة ، حركه
واضحًا في جولة أخرى ، حركه وعليك
القيام بذلك ست مرات ، ويتطلب الأمر
صبرًا ، حيث يحتوي المسدس الحديث
على أسطوانة تخرج من
الإطار
لذلك يمكنني أن أقول على الفور أن هذا
فارغ ويمكنني الضغط على زر
ويسقط كل الجولات على الفور حتى
تتمكن من معرفة ما إذا كان فارغًا ، لست
مضطرًا للقيام بذلك واحدًا تلو الآخر
[موسيقى]
هولندي ، هل يمكنك أن تشرح للجمهور
مزيد من المعلومات حول الرصاص ، يبدو الأمر وكأنه
مجنون كيف
يطلق عليه اسم
استوديو فارغ للأمان في الاستوديو ، وهو الاسم الكامل
الذي نطلق عليه اسم فارغ
للاختزال ويمكنك أن ترى أنه يبدو يشبه إلى
حد كبير رصاصة باستثناء
عدم وجود جولة  لا يوجد رصاص
يخرج من المسدس وليس هناك مقذوف ، لذا
فهو يشبه إلى حد كبير خرطوشة
مثل الرصاصة العادية ،
ومع ذلك يمكنك أن ترى بوضوح شديد عدم
وجود رصاصة رصاصية ، ومن الصعب جدًا
ارتكاب خطأ مثل هذا
جيدًا ، إنه أمر صعب جدًا  حتى لا
تلاحظ الفرق بين الجولة الفارغة
والدائرية على الرغم من أن الجولات الوهمية تبدو إلى
حد كبير مثل رصاصة حقيقية كما
يفترض أن تفعل ذلك ، فإذا تعامل أحد الممثلين مع أحدها
أمام الكاميرا ، فإنه يبدو وكأنه شيء حقيقي
ولكن أحد أفراد الطاقم أو درعًا على وجه الخصوص
ستعرف أن هذا ليس بسبب ما
فعلناه بدلاً من البارود بداخلنا ،
وضعنا بارودًا وتلك الصغيرة
تتأرجح حولها حتى لا تراها أبدًا على
الكاميرا ولكن الطاقم سيعرفون هذا
ليس بارودًا بل هو بارود ، لذا فقط أفعل
ذلك  حسنًا ، تعلم أن أطفالي في السيارة
يبكون
لأنكم تتابعون كل ما
أريد أن أفعله من باب المجاملة لك.
هل هذا
هو ، أنا فقط أطلب
منا أن نجلس كمجاملة الآن للتحدث إليكم الآن ، من
فضلكم فقط لا تتابعونا
لبقية الأمر ، فقط اتركونا قدمنا لكم كل
يء ، شكرًا لكم ، دع
ا نتحدث عن أليك بالدوين ما
ا  هل تعتقد أنه مسؤول فهو
أحد المحترفين  الطواقم الذين يعملون في هذا المشروع
جيدًا ، ليس بالنسبة لي بصراحة أن أقول
من هو المسؤول جزئيًا لأن
الأدلة لم تظهر كلها حتى الآن ، فإن
التحقيق مع العمدة في
مقاطعة سانتا في لم يحضر محامي المقاطعة
بعد كل خطوة على الطريق بالضبط.
ممثل في منصب أليك بالدوين ،
هل كان سيكون منتجًا تنفيذيًا ، لذا
ربما كان مسؤولاً عن
بعض الأموال على الرغم من أنه ربما
كان أكثر من منتج غير فعال
ويفعل ما يجب أن يركز عليه الممثل على
دوره وهذا هو الإجراء الصحيح
[  موسيقى]
أخبرنا بما حدث مع صديقك
قبل تصوير هذا الفيلم ،
كان هناك سيد الدعامة الذي عُرض عليه
هذه الوظيفة أولاً وضع ميزانية وكانت
تلك الميزانية مخصصة لخمسة
مساعدين ولديك خمسة أو ستة أسابيع من
التحضير للفيلم
عاد المنتجون إليه مع عرض مضاد
قائلين إنه سيكون لدينا
مساعدان وواحد من هؤلاء
المساعدين سوف يتضاعف كدرع
سيقاضونه بواجب مزدوج وهم ليسوا كذلك
سأمنحك الأسابيع الخمسة من الإعدادية
التي سيحصل عليها أسبوعين ، لذا
مر هذا المعلم الدعائي بالفيلم وقال
إنني لا أريد أن أحصل على أي جزء منه
لا يبدو أنه وصفة للنجاح
هولندي ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك  لشرح
كل شيء من أجلي وتشرفنا بحضورك
في العرض ، شكرًا
لاستضافتي وفهم أن هوليوود تفعل
ذلك بأمان وسنواصل القيام
بذلك ، شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]